what do you think is this going to be a
long game and here we go it's finally
starting my prediction
yeah a very rare first move from magnus
carlton he's pushed his g pawn forward
just one square getting really ready not
even the b pawn it's not even the b pawn
which we saw a lot last season
popularized by adiban of course the
indian grandmaster first move
okay rtmf does reply it brings this
knight out and there we go it sits on
the g2 square where it has great range
and now i'm curious to see what kind of
strategy i'll tell me if we'll
will adapt because here here is just
answer it he's put his pawn on light
squares so well i expect all the pawns
to go on the light squares from now on
from artemiev and there we go one thing
that we expected to see throughout the
tour was magnus eating noodles he's at
it again already in the first game of
the championship yeah
served him well last year well mostly
well yeah i was a little bit up and down
actually yeah
a noodle gambit and now we see both
players revert to more standard
more normal types of development white
has got the king castled now challenging
the black central pawn before black's
king is safe gaining as much space as
possible he actually captures
we see a porn trade i was about to say i
had a serious case of deja vu because
just last week i played a friendly game
against magnus and it was in the exact
position as black i brought my knight
out but uh here artemis just chooses to
release the tension
uh by exchanging a set of pawns and i
mentioned black has gone upon up but
it's not going to last long
he's taking the time to consider what
type of
position he should be going for so now
he castles the king that's a very
natural move and after knight takes pawn
it's here where he has to make that
decision and he's done it he's actually
pushed his pawn forward see pawn two
squares
that's actually not the main line the
main line was actually developing the
knight
on the left side okay he doesn't push
the central pawn he pushes the b pawn so
something that you mentioned kaia the b3
opening just slightly delayed
he saved it from move eight of symmetry
with his bishops both bishops going out
to their longest possible diagonals
they're going to try and create that
crisscross effect later on yeah like
just bringing a knight out there and
magnus will for sure bring out his dark
squared bishop there is one notable game
between ding loren and neil shanklin but
okay there white actually won
okay that's important to know we love
our stats here right so yes um the fact
that white has a good score or at least
among top level players from this
position means
um it might be quite promising also we
should mention it's a new season but we
still have the evaluation bar just above
the player's cameras and right now the
evaluation bar says white has a 0.9
advantage so if it goes over to the left
it means white's doing well if it goes
over to the right black is doing better
so
um we'll keep an eye on that we won't
trust it yet it's still early days but
uh yeah i do quite like white's position
i love the two white bishops very
flexibly placed and uh the computer
seems to approve of what magnus is doing
as well um so meanwhile magnus just
pushed his pawn for one square which
means he wants maximum attention um that
we'll see big fluctuations in rating
magnus he loves his numbers he loves his
stats i think maybe more than anyone in
the chess world and if he gets 2900 i'm
sure in the tour i'm sure we'll see him
brag about it and uh
okay so um our tamiya has actually moved
his queen forward connecting the two
rooks together means the two rooks are
indestructible i uh like that kind of
idea these two pieces they do line up on
the same diagonal as ivanka mentioned if
white just takes a time out just
improves the rook a very natural move
the bishop might spring forward and this
is one thing for all the viewers at home
i recommend not to do never ever take
the bishop on black's terms or on your
opponent's terms because this would
allow firstly a
bad trade white's bishop there is a key
piece but secondly it would allow the
black queen into the position suddenly
black has ideas next move of bringing
the knight forward maybe later on if the
stars line trying to checkmate the white
king the white king does not feel safe
now because the black queen is so near
checking out throughout this tournament
the air quality stats
yeah um so okay meanwhile both sides
have just brought their rooks to the
center that idea that your man can
mention to bring the bishop forward keep
that one in mind for later
okay magnus has jumped forward with the
knight so he's actually combined all the
ideas we mentioned and now we have seen
a trade of one set of knights
and the black queen is under attack she
has to move she has to find herself on a
safe square and i guess he would be kind
of considering if he steps forward with
the queen one square then maybe you know
he'll be and okay and it's happening on
the board and i was wondering whether
maybe white now can strike in the center
because you know this is something that
magnus will always have in the pocket
you know the pawn will the deep the
there's a lot of tension on this line
and it's not clear who opening the
position up will favor so uh i think now
taking this pawn would probably be a
mistake for black because it would allow
the white knight forward attacking this
rook attacking a pawn and this white
knight amply protected by these two
pieces this would be real trouble now
for black and uh well we all wish
alexandre castanec the best of luck and
oh well magnus has advanced his another
pawn and now there's even more tension
in the position
and uh wow oh yeah the question is
thrown back to artemyev what's he going
to do how is he going to handle that
because presumably it's the same idea
after pawn takes born that white knight
can
jump into that square behind the scenes
action um some news we have a new
podcast coming out as well we'll talk
about that a bit later um so yeah go
check out that facebook page definitely
david and a mystery guest we will review
later on
and meanwhile some action on the board i
did mention black's knight probably
wanted to jump out of the way just to
open up the black dart squad bishop and
that did happen black's knight retreated
we saw white capture a knight and now
actually both the dark square bishops
have been traded off they have
disappeared from the board and
this i quite like it from artemis side
he simplified the position but then
again
it feels like magnus maybe has a small
advantage um just because of the fact he
will have an extra central pawn a bit
later on maybe now for example magnus
can initiate even more trades take off
one of the black pawns open up a line
for his rook
and
yeah it feels like black maybe
temporarily at least on the back foot um
as i mentioned actually i played darth
vader a few months ago i was playing for
england he was playing for russia at the
european team championship and every
move i was thinking okay i can't give
him an end game i can't give him a
simple position he will trick me he will
outplay me
so i was lucky just having watched lots
of his games on the tour that i learned
a bit about his style but magnus is
actually going against that advice he
did trade off some pawns he did trade
off one set of rooks now we mentioned
white's rook has found an open line
white's rook on that c file is fantastic
but it might get traded off at some
point by black blacks rook even now
could just sidestep one square trade off
those rooks and suddenly i'll tell you
he's in a position where he thrives um
all of the danger is gone white doesn't
have any material left to go on an
attack against the black king no real
checkmating ideas
white just pushing harry the h pawn
there trying to maybe push it forward
even further but
black can
block the push of that pawn black and
trade rooks it feels like artemiev is
guiding this game towards safety on the
left side of the board
and that means that in a king and pawn
ending he would have
almost a winning advantage yep if the
queens come off actually then i think
black is the only one who can win
because of that two versus one uh
majority over there as you mentioned uh
ivanka so i think magnus really needs to
keep the queens on because he needs to
be active he's now pushing in the center
but white central pawns take an age to
push forward and to break through to
create a passport um i i think black has
has the upper hand here i agree with you
and magnus actually following the rule
book the rule book says that when you
have a past pawn you should push him
and he's doing that uh but yeah maybe a
slightly careless move by artemis
favorite pawn structure yeah
he's not holding back yeah three pawns
all sitting in the same row wow
that's ambitious i'm very surprised
because i just talked about king safety
and now white's king is not entirely
safe anymore but
i like the idea behind it what just
wants to throw everything forward in the
center but you kind of you hinted at you
hinters ideas and you start putting
those ghosts in the position and there
we see it we see our tamiya has reacted
to the threat and he's pushed his pawn
in the center i mean
that is
wow i'm surprised by that because it's
allowed magnus the best type of pawn you
can possibly get which is a protected
past pawn okay that spawn is going to
push itself forward
um and maybe having two double pawns is
not necessarily better than having uh
one strong past porn and yeah you're
right your instincts were correct there
your anchor just three or four moves ago
so magnus has definitely gained
something over the last few turns and
now okay black's pawn's done too much
forward and white taking a time out to
shuffle the king to the corner to safety
big moment does artem have continue i
think he has to just in practical terms
he has to continue pushing those pawns
in your anchor yeah both sides now uh
playing their main ideas black pushing
his pawns forward on the side he's
stronger on this side of the board white
now trying to trade bishops once the
bishops disappear as they have done now
white queen is going to try and snake
her way in uh to the black position
she's going to offer a trade of queens
maybe try to
start checking the black king and yeah
pawn endings which is always activate
your queen maximize her potential okay
i'll tell you i've given a check he
doesn't have much time on the clock and
now the white king starts finding a safe
place i think black has to activate his
king now because okay there we go the
black king was doing nothing not
contributing
um
white central pawn there the white d5
pawn the past pawn is going to start
marching at some point so the black king
has to move towards it
but the computer has shot up suddenly um
what could white's idea be it feels like
white has to activate the queen now you
find a safe place for your king and
that's it okay so magnus is given a
check so we were maybe advocating this
move the white queen hitting some pawns
and
as you mentioned ivanka potentially uh
magnus was scared of the black queen
jumping forward this way uh to try and
sneak in towards the king or maybe even
this way but instead magnus has given a
check and uh now the black king has had
to run away magnus now um what's he
planning maybe he's going to jump into
the position with his queen maybe the
black king just not on a great square
now it's in a dark square it might get
checked
okay magnus actually chooses the square
we mentioned but he's worsened the
position of the black king first so now
if the black queen does jump forward
white does have a nasty nasty check
hitting the king and next move gobbling
up a black pawn and i'm taking a look at
the clock situation here on my computer
and i can see seconds remaining and okay
yeah no i think it's a mistake from
artemiev because now magnus has this
check that we mentioned he's played it
the black king has run and it's a double
attack and now magnus okay he's he's
winning all he needs to do let's go back
to the place he needs to bring his queen
back swap the queens and then this pawn
will match up and win let's go back to
the players is magnus gonna find the
winning move bringing his queen back and
trading off the black queen
ivanka does that just win on the spot it
wins on the spot and it's on the board
he's found it and look at this it's a
pawn race but white pawns are going to
be just
one move quicker
and uh there we go white's gonna
continue pushing that pawn in the center
i think the queens there's tension there
but it's as if they don't exist so the
queens have traded i think the black
king is might even get checkmated i hope
we see checkmate on the board
is about to allow this two queens and
then magnus will deliver checkmate
oh no he's going to resign is he before
checkmate no allows the tech mate show
us the checkmate vladislav ah
well
what a start though for magnus carlsen
in the the championship 2022 what a win
and what a game